the man who wrote last week's report
about the FBI's investigation into the
Hillary Clinton email scandal was on
Capitol Hill this afternoon to answer
questions and defend his conclusions
along with him the FBI director who is
promising to change things and hold
people accountable chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge shows
us what happened I want you to reopen
this investigation a senior Republican
senator drilled down on the anti-trump
text messages between FBI agent Peter
strong can FBI lawyer Lisa Paige the
2016 meeting was about a quote insurance
policy discussed and then FBI deputy
director Anju McCabe's office struck
texted about the meeting that McCabe
apparently could not remember yes mister
we did he said he was not he did not
recall the ones lying senator Graham
said the text reeked of political bias
and the Inspector General's conclusions
are off-base I'm glad you found what you
found mr. Rhodes I'm not buying that the
Clinton email investigation was on the
up and up the first public testimony
from Inspector General Michael Horowitz
an FBI director Christopher Rae about
the Clinton email report divided along
party lines director Ray has quite a
mess to clean up I think he probably
knows that the Inspector General found
no evidence a political bias in the
FBI's investigation like the Secretary
Clinton or in the decision not to pursue
criminal charges Horowitz testified the
FBI has also asked him to investigate
former FBI director James Comey for
making at least one memo that documented
private conversations with President
Trump we received a referral on that
from the FBI we are handling that
referral and we will issue a report when
the matter is complete Democrats pressed
on alleged leaks in the fall of 2016 two
former New York City Mayor turned
president Trump attorney Rudy Giuliani
can you assure the American people that
there are no ongoing leagues from any
office of the FBI to Rudolph Giuliani
I'm certainly not aware of any we are
aggressively investigating a number of
leaks even as we speak
based on the reports findings the FBI
director said a half dozen employees
could be disciplined but he emphasized
the mistakes and bad
were limited this report is focused on a
specific set of events back in 2016 and
a small number of FBI employees
connected with those events one
republican was not satisfied let's
remember who that small number of
employees was the director of the FBI
the Deputy Director of the FBI the
leader of both the Clinton email
investigation and the Russia
investigation the Inspector General will
testify for a second day in front of two
house panels tomorrow in a separate
development after months of pressure the
lawyer for FBI agent Peter struck has
now confirmed that he will voluntarily
testify before the House Judiciary
Committee and any other congressional
inquiry right that will be interesting
Katherine Harris table on the hill Cathy
thank you